Dr. Zakia, it's a topic that you and I
love very much together and I know that
of course you are an authority in the
world about it. Alhamdulillah by the
grace and mercy of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala.
>> I prefer calling myself a student
>> inshallah
>> Islam and compatible religion. I know a
lot of the viewers would consider you to
be an authority on the topic doubt and
non-Muslims and I think that's why it's
an incredibly important show that we're
going to start today. I'd like to ask
you the first question which is first
and foremost in any scientific analysis
of any topic which is to define the
topic define the term daer
and to from our last show on islah how
does that differ from da alhamdulillah
bishop
As far as the word dawa is concerned,
when anyone hears the word dawat,
especially the people from the
subcontinent India and Pakistan, the
moment they hear the word dawat,
immediately they start thinking of
mutton biryani or chicken biryani. they
start thinking of a lunch party.
Dawat does not mean a lunch party. Dava
or Dawat means an invitation.
And today we will not be discussing
about an invitation to a lunch party or
dinner party. We are discussing about da
Islam the invitation to Islam. And an
invitation can only be given to an
outsider. So dawa that is the reason can
be only done to a non-Muslim. When we
give information about Islam to a
non-Muslim inviting him towards Islam
the Arabic word used is dawa
and the meaning of Arabic word Islamah
is to repair.
It means to improve. So when we speak
about Islam to a Muslim, giving him more
information about Islam, the more
appropriate word is Islam. Though both
these words are interchangeable,
but if you want to use specifically the
word Islam is used when we speak about
Islam to a Muslim, giving him more
information and dava is a word used when
we speak about Islam to a non-Muslim
inviting him toward the fold of Islam.
>> Okay. Right. Thank you for that
definition. That's a very good start,
inshallah.